did you see biden getting challenged
yesterday
yeah did you see that yeah
a little bit yeah but you know what that
was a lot for george i thought a lot i
thought it was good i mean just the fact
that he asked him a follow-up question
and pushed him a little yeah yeah i love
the guy on brian williams i love that
guy on brian williams you know brian
williams said he teased it up that's
right he teased it up saying you have to
give biden credit right and uh he he he
took it on the chin and he he claimed
responsibility he didn't run from it and
the guy was like uh was i watching the
same thing you guys are watching
he went off for one minute
and it was a direct call i said what are
you talking about we told him how to do
it didn't follow anything just decided
to do it on i told him this would happen
we begged him not to do that yes and in
the interview with george george says
did you see did you think this was going
to take place yes
were you prepared for this thing yes
would you have done anything differently
no
could you have done anything better no
mean we can go back and look at it but
no and then it was pretty yeah
you know i'm not a veteran i wasn't in
the military but i am just disgusted by
what's going on for people that served
over there and served in in the in the
u.s armed forces i mean think about pat
tillman remember when he died and what a
big deal that was in afghanistan
he was a detroit no arizona cardinal i
went to asu straight phoenix all the way
and he grew up in san jose that was us
yeah i know that was friendly fire but
it happened over there and then you
think did everything they do all the
deaths was it for nothing the taliban
was in charge when we came there they're
in charge again now yeah i mean it's
almost like a big uh you know it's um i
i actually i got a bunch of it's
interesting you say that time because i
got a bunch of messages i have a few
followers that that are armed armed
forces people and they're awesome
awesome awesome people my buddy jesse
actually took uh got got shot you know
over there and he he's got he has a
tattoo around the bullet wounds that say
infidel but um
he's a beast but his whole thing was is
like i gotta tell you man 20 years later
do are we more secure or less secure
like serious question and the fact that
you can even debate whether or not we're
more secure or less secure today just
goes to show you the failure and the
waste you know and there was there was
um one guy who messaged me and said man
you know it's it's incredible this
started with americans
jumping out of uh out of the world trade
centers and it ends with afghanis
falling off of airplanes like
this is this is a humanitarian tragedy
man like this is this is something that
we're all going to look at at our you
know while we were complicit and you
know there's a reason why ron paul was
right was trending on twitter all day
yesterday ron paul was right ron paul
you know
you don't like him we you know you
interviewed him you people he's crazy
maybe he's not the best messenger maybe
you don't like his son rand whatever
if you look at what he said for the last
30 years about american foreign policy
and fiscal policy particularly i i defy
anybody to show me where he's been wrong
where he has been the lone person making
sense in our federal government well
i'll add to one thing gerard said are we
safer or less safe that's an easy answer
look at afghanistan's neighbor china
okay so china has unfettered access into
afghanistan right now and the last thing
too i think biden's messaging is so off
right now he should as the
commander-in-chief and as the president
be emphatic that we're getting everybody
out and and basically their message from
the department of defense is hey if we
can make the deadline you know that
biden has set and if you can get to the
kabul airport we'll get you out but my
god
i'm assuming special forces are inside
that country right now helping us and
doing it and just doing it under the
radar you know if you're listening to
this and you are either in afghani
yourself okay and you just left you used
to live over there or you're a vet
marine army whatever maybe and you were
in afghanistan you did a tour please
comment below or send us a text to
310-340-1132 can you put that in the
comment section
3103
again if you're an afghani who lived
there
or if you're somebody who served in the
military and you were in afghanistan
texas at 310-340-132
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]